now in studio with more reaction Florida
Congressman he's a rising star on the
Republican Party Byron Donalds is with
us
by the way I want all of you to know
this you have been under attack because
your wife your wife happens to be white
yeah you have come on to fire you've
been called a prop by congresswoman
Corey Bush you have been sent a copy of
Uncle Tom's Cabin
uh it has been you know it's clear he
has no problem being used was written
about you
and they have the Congressional Black
Caucus right yeah and you wanted to join
that caucus yeah I did when I first got
into Congress yeah and what happened
uh well frankly what happened was is
that there was never an opportunity for
me to join they wouldn't let you in no
why
there was never an answer and I stopped
asking so is it the liberal Black Caucus
or is it the or is it the Congressional
Black Caucus well I mean right now it's
the liberal Congressional Black Caucus
right but I think Sean here's the here's
the bigger thing
you know should Hakeem Jeffries
apologize obviously for what he wrote in
that essay 100 not just to me but to
Burgess Owens to Wesley hunt uh to John
James to Tim Scott but also to me a love
to Alan West and all the black
Republicans that have spent time in
conversation you mentioned there's a
friend of mine but here's the bigger
thing I'm kind of over the the phony
apologies let's have a real debate about
black conservatism versus black
liberalism let's actually have a real
honest conversation about whose policies
are actually going to unleash not just
Black America but all of America because
I think that's the debate that the
American people need to have right now
I'll invite any one of your critics
including Hakeem Jeffries on this show I
will do a full hour debate one-on-one
you versus them and and let's see what
the American people decide
[Applause]
Democratic leader
leader Representatives that not only
support it as controversial uncle but we
all know that Louis Farrakhan is a
radical racist and a virulent
anti-semite right okay so there are
people the the leader of the Democratic
Party in the House of Representatives
supports that man
and my question is what if it was a
republican we already know what would
happen if it was a republican the calls
will be coming out for resignations you
would have you know some members of the
Republican party will be you know
clinching their fists and clenching
their pearls saying oh my gosh oh my
gosh you got to go I want to see where
Democrats go with this uh where's the
media where's CNN where's MSNBC are they
going to in the press conferences as
Hakeem Jeffries day after day after day
are they going to let him give out his
comment through his staff by the way and
then just let them move on to the next
subject because if this was Kevin
McCarthy if this was Paul Ryan if this
was John Boehner it would be
never-ending Saga about why is such a
person leading one of the prominent
parties in America do you believe that
African-Americans Hispanic Americans or
minorities that Democrats claim to have
a monopoly of compassion for are now
moving towards conservatism because I
believe conservatives Republicans have
become the party of the working class in
this country and I see Democrats as the
party of coastal Elites 100 listen I was
at a basketball tournament last weekend
with my son my 15 year old son I was
stopped by two wins when you play
one-on-one he wins now he's young man
he's got young legs I got to give it to
him he's good I trained him well yeah
he's good he's good I hate it my son
used to use my moves that I used on him
on me
I got stopped literally and I'm gonna
work in work clothes I'm in gym gym
shorts stopped by two black men
recognized me said you know what I
appreciate what you stand for I
appreciate what you're doing you keep
going
they're not Republicans but they
appreciated
I appreciate having gotten to know you
sure your family is here your beautiful
mom is with you and and other friends of
yours are here you're doing an amazing
job you have emerged as a real leader in
the Republican caucus and we appreciate
you taking time to come by
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else